it may be hard to believe but this tiny
insect has wreaked havoc on the world
killing as many as 50 billion people
over the course of human existence it's
a startling number and it's had a huge
impact on our history it's all detailed
in the new book the mosquito a human
history of our deadliest predator and
this climate change helps to fuel their
migration North mankind is still trying
to sort out its relationship with its
biggest foe at any moment across the
globe she leads the news the mosquitoes
mosquitoes
the mosquito mosquitoes infecting tens
of thousands with disease merida mexico
south of our border among the cities now
in her sights
how bad would mosquitoes serious events
can almost become witnessed I'm telling
Duda they have fever when they advise
them that's one of the signs of dengue
fever survivor Maria del Sol la Paix is
on the offensive
allowing indoor insecticide spraying in
her home an innovative approach in the
war on mosquitoes we can have a
reduction of over 70% in the number of
mosquitoes for up to six months
four times more effective than aerial
sprayings says Professor Gonzalo Basque
as pro kopeck who's part of a team from
Emory University
that's allied with scientists from the
Autonomous University of the Yucatan why
is this important to people in the
United States we have the mosquitoes in
the US so the more we know about methods
that can control them the more
applicable they might become and we have
people who especially this time of the
year they're traveling on their
vacations they're going to different
destinations and those destinations tend
also to be areas that have a decent GPA
mosquitoes is this mosquito territory
it could be territorial 110 trillion of
them at any given time historian Timothy
Winegard author of the book the mosquito
is fascinated by the bug especially the
female because she's the one who bites
and transmits disease he says we weren't
her only prey 70% of dinosaur species
regionally were either extinct or
endangered by the time the meteor
crashes into the Yucatan Peninsula come
on you're saying that the dinosaur was
endangered by the mosquito certain
dinosaur species were certainly either
already extinct or endangered from
mosquito born in San fly borne diseases
but Winegard says putting man's
relationship with the mosquito into
context is even more mind-blowing she
was far more lethal than the minds of
the most brilliant generals or man-made
weapons disease up until the Second
World War took 65% of deaths on the
battlefield think of that Caesar
Hannibal Genghis Khan the Crusaders and
every invasion migration and conflict so
depending on immunity or where the wars
were fought one side usually benefited
from her destruction of the other side
and she I mean decided that the fate of
empires and nations and countless Wars
and certainly from Alexander all the way
to the Second World War
mosquitoes likely hitched a ride aboard
the Nina Pinta and Santa Maria and
thousands of slave ships that
transported human cargo across the
Atlantic they very
we started vectoring malaria and other
diseases and Africans had an immunity
right which is partly why they became
such a lucrative commodity on the
plantation systems European indentured
servants or workers were dying in droves
of mosquito-borne disease then there's
the American Revolution the forces of
generals Washington and Lafayette didn't
do it by themselves but they had a
little help they had a lot of help
Cornwallis says very clearly to his
commander General Clinton and also in
his diary that this surrender was not
caused by anything you know the
Americans are French did but because he
had roughly 35% of his troops available
to fight because they were absolutely
shredded by malaria so the birth of our
nation we owe to the mosquitoes indeed
she is a founding mother of the United
States still she played millions of
Americans from the end of the 17th
century to the beginning of the 20th
with malaria and yellow fever the death
toll from yellow fever alone was more
than a hundred thousand the CDC was
established in 1946 and at that time I
was known as the communicable disease
Center and before that the office of
malaria Control says CDC research
entomologist dr. John gymnic its mission
was to protect US troops and the
government even enlisted the likes of
Theodor Seuss Geisel better known as dr.
Seuss
don't be killer good and dead along with
Walt Disney and his Seven Dwarves
by the mid-1950s the u.s. curbed the
spread of most mosquito-borne illnesses
DDT our main weapon of choice though
highly effective it was discontinued in
part for polluting the environment
impossible links to cancer gymnic says
now the highly adaptable predator is
back on the hunt and gaining ground
so we're monitoring to make sure that
they remain susceptible to the the
chemicals that we apply and then of
course we want to look for new tools and
as she expands her range across the
planet human defense is moving to what
some describe as a form of biological
warfare scientist Abdi L Martin Park is
raising male mosquitoes infected with
the bacteria called Baba Kea that
effectively sterilizes them you need a
wild mosquito female ya to mate with the
infected mosquito would be me the dick
is going to be dead some have already
questioned the ethics of such approaches
which include going even further
altering the DNA of the insect to
inhibit its ability to transmit disease
it's all on the mind of scientists like
Professor Vasquez Pro Quebec who are
leading the charge will there be a day
that we won't have these epidemics
anymore we hope so that's in a way the
goal that all of us the scientists have
to have a positive benefit in a world in
which we might still have some
circulation of these pathogens but the
harm they produce would be so minimum
that we won't have to worry about it
there are so many agencies and
nonprofits that are working to help rid
these mosquito-borne illnesses Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation to the CDC but
the big question is should we write we
might be able to borrow our world yes
part of the world and we clearly do not
know at this point the research is still
out my question was about the one woman
at the beginning when she was spraying
the insecticide inside her home which
they say can be effective but you have
to worry a little bit about what kind
ones on your spring inside your home
like Terminix coming in right